what is your strategy to win big brother
my strategy to win big brother canada is
to find one or two people i can trust
and take them all the way to the end
perfect uh what kind of personality will
you class with in the house the only
person that i'd clash with in the house
is somebody who is going to try to be a
bigger personality than me just to put
me down because nobody can be a bigger
personality than me
perfect uh showman's or no man
it's going to be a no-mance
simply because it's going to be against
my game it's gonna go against my game
and my thinking for a nomance but that
doesn't completely shut the door on it i
could fall in love i don't know you
could find your your number one your
soulmate i could find my personality
if i find my soulmate i would ride or
die with them to the end um and why is
canada gonna work for you
i think canada's gonna root for me
because they're gonna see that i'm
genuine i'm positive i'm somebody that
they can really understand because i'm
down to earth just like every other
canadian is so i think people will like
me for that